un día monumental en la lucha contra la
violencia armada eso dijo joe biden tras
firmar una ley bipartidista que parecía
inimaginable hasta la reciente serie de
tiroteos masivos en el país el último de
ellos la masacre de 19 estudiantes dos
profesoras en una escuela primaria de
walt de texas el 24 de mayo ward se
salvarán vidas a nuestro regreso de
europa
hill y yo organizaremos un acto en la
casa blanca el 11 de julio para celebrar
este logro histórico con los miembros
que votaron por estas familias y las
familias que de hecho fueron víctimas de
los tiroteos que hemos visto y lewis y
el texto es el acto más impactante sobre
la violencia con armas de fuego
producido por el congreso desde 1993 sin
embargo están lejos de lo que quería
originalmente bailan o incluye por
ejemplo la prohibición de las armas de
asalto lo que se incluye es una refuerzo
a la comprobación de antecedentes
penales y psicológicos de los
compradores de armas de entre 18 y 21
años bloqueara también la venta de armas
a los condenados por maltrato a sus
parejas aunque no estén legalmente
casados
dará a los estados a poner en marcha
leyes de banderas rojas que faciliten a
las autoridades la retirada de armas a
personas consideradas peligrosas
irónicamente la firma del proyecto de
ley llega pocos días después de que el
tribunal supremo falló en contra una ley
del estado de nueva york que prohibía
llevar armas de fuego en público